Winchester Mystery House is an incredibly unique Victorian mansion...
...created by Sarah Winchester, heiress to the Winchester Repeating Arms fortune.
Sarah Winchester had a series of unfortunate things happen to her,...
...including the death of her husband and daughter.
She was a spiritualist and visited a medium to try and understand why.
The medium said, well, "The gun that won the West."
There's a lot of karma there, so head west and build a house to appease the spirits.
She started construction in 1884, which didn't stop till the day she died.
The house is a 160-room Victorian mansion with no master plan.
There's a lot of strange attributes.
There are 40 staircases, 40 fireplaces, four elevators.
We have a number of staircases that lead right to the ceiling,...
...doors that open up into nothing, or it's just a wall.
The house is known for its spirits, who many people believe are the ghosts of people...
...who worked at the house or even Sarah herself.
A lot of our guests and employees have had very strange things happen to them in this house.
Sometimes, it's just footsteps or hearing a voice,...
...a light that flickers, or sometimes it's an actual full, physical manifestation.